ah we are live
has amazon prime actually wanted
stargate for a lot longer than we
thought
welcome to sidetrack your sci-fi tv a
movie channel
[Music]
hello and welcome to everybody and
welcome to sidetrack i've already got a
load of people in the comments really
nice to see you all
i'm just gonna throw it straight out
there
um
as you know i've had a few sources
working in around amazon um and mgm
sorry um but i've been slowly building
up a bit of a network of people i talked
to and i've had a new person i've
started to talk to that actually works
partly for em amazon
works does some um stuff for amazon
prime
he actually is the one that told me
recently the amazon are still really
really interested in stargate and that
they seem to be taking the project
in-house so it won't necessarily be mgm
that make the new stargate series when
it gets made
and it will actually be amazon prime or
amazon studios
been talking a bit more though because
there's been some a bit of confusion
knocking around about
when certain scripts were made um and
what's been what's been going on with um
where we're at really with mgm and
um the new stargate series
so
just to this is this is really off the
bat
i had a conversation or brad wright
actually sent me a message a little
while ago off one of my videos and he
basically said
you keep saying that um i created a
script a year ago
and that that's the one melody has seen
um and that i rewrote that following
pressure from amazon and he said that's
not true
well i actually agree with him it's not
true and i don't actually think i said
that i did imply it in my last statement
when i very very quickly summed it all
up into
this final script was made under
pressure from amazon but
as you know if you've watched a lot of
these videos before
i've discussed that many times in more
detail
and i've said repeatedly
amazon were feeding back to mgm but
amazon could not force brad wright to do
anything because amazon didn't own mgm
at the time and i've said that a lot
but it did make me think because brad
wright actually said at that point
that he didn't write that script that
joseph milose recently tweeted out on
um until
um actually he wrote it before
um cove it happened
right now that is actually contrary to
something he said to me about three or
four months ago when he commented on one
of my other videos and he actually said
at the time that the final draft he
wrote that about a year ago so we talked
about maybe 18 months ago now
obviously covert has been going on
it's nearly three years ago i would say
that that would happen so
so a bit of a bit of confusion there so
i went back to my chap who works amazon
who works for amazon and i said to him
when
was amazon's interest in stargate
because we always assumed because we've
never been told anything different that
amazon's interest in amazon stargate
started around the time the sale went
through
he came back to me immediately said no
amazon's interest in stargate was from
the very beginning it was from day one
so
amazon and mgm were actually talking
about stargate before covid and before
brad wright was ordered to create the
pilot now that
is quite big news in lots of ways
because we're in a position at the
moment where we're
in a bit of limbo
the main update right now is that
actually nothing is happening with
stargate at amazon
amazon and everyone i've spoken to says
everything is on hold everyone i speak
to mgm say almost every project that's
not in sort of like final production has
gone on hold
nothing else major has happened since
the
um contracts and things and the big the
big day a few weeks ago and lots of
people suddenly told well your contracts
are being
they're not being carried on and
basically a lot of people put on guard
and leave and basically
escorted out of the building and by
guard
and ever since then everything seems to
come very very quiet
there are going to be no new projects
announced anytime soon is what i'm being
told
and that so what does that mean for
stargate means that all this work that
had been done on brad wright's initial
script is still just sat there doing
nothing
my chat but amazon says all of that
stuff that is now at amazon prime and
they are going through it all but
nothing is going to happen at the moment
because mgm has to have a massive
restructure
and amazon prime have actually
had a bit of a financial issue through
quite a big stock decrease stock price
decrease but also just people are not
tuning into as many scriptions as they
were scriptures before subscribing to
amazon prime acceptor as they were
so
everything's on hold until that happens
but this news that amazon prime were
interested in stargate even before the
sale of mgm was announced
is interesting because it basically
means amazon have been sniffing around
stargate for more than three years
there is absolutely no way they are not
going to push forward a project that
they've been working on or interested in
for three years
so
what are we going to do so what's what's
that mean basically for stargate what
does that mean for this confusion about
the scripts
one thing i've been told repeatedly from
lots of different sources is the amazon
have not been particularly excited by
brad wright's in um vision for the
stargate series he was very worried that
the amazon basically wanted him to think
a lot bigger and this is what brad
wright was pointing out to me that the
ihean didn't do the rewrite because he
was ordered by amazon to do it and he's
right he wasn't because that feedback
would have gone through mgm because
amazon doesn't own mgm at the time
amazon only owns mgm from about six
weeks two months ago
but amazon were interested and it looks
like amazon was potentially looking to
buy the stargate series themselves
even as early as july 2019
this is before brad wright was ordered
to do the pilot they were in
conversations with mgm but nothing could
be announced according to my source
because mgm hadn't agreed who they were
going to sell to now amazon were
interested and were looking to bid at
that time but so is apple and so was
somebody else possibly warned with i
can't remember who the other person was
but it was definitely apple
and they were
not sure who they were going to sell to
so nothing could be sort of like
publicly discussed
but privately
amazon wanted stargate for amazon prime
that really blows everything up because
then we're talking about all these rooms
i keep getting told that amazon were
giving feedback back to brad wright
through mgm
basically means that it's it's
irrelevant what we were told what we
assumed that happened or started happen
from the sale it actually was happening
from day one even before bad bright was
even involved it was happening they were
already given feedback back then
it would have been informal it would
have been oh maybe you should do this
maybe we should do that but that seems
to be how the process works brad wright
himself in a tweet and again and a
message to me said that he has he did
write several pilots he did write
several different scripts and lots and
lots of different versions
all of those versions
um were completely used and done with
feedback through the development process
is what he called it but that
development process is he writes a
script he sends it to mgm mgm executives
read it they kick about the office a bit
they send him notes which then go back
to brad right he does a rewrite based on
that and they go through that process
doing several rewrites until they get
something they're happy with
now if this apparently happened before
covid but i actually know it happened
sort of after cover so it was over that
christmas period over a few months
when he said he hasn't written that
final script for 18 months i think he
was just like uncovered brain or
something because i think brad wright is
actually really really honest he's
really happy to talk to fans and things
he sent me a few messages now and um
he's actually mentioned sidetrack a
couple of times um so you know i don't
think he's being dishonest i don't think
he's playing games
what i do think oh i do think he's
playing games a little bit we'll talk
about that in a minute
so
amazon were involved from day one before
brad wright even got involved brad
wright writes the script sent it to mgm
mgm because they're trying to type this
and trying to sell this terms and prime
for their tv show
send it to amazon prime they send notes
amazon mgm kicking around the office
themselves they send notes brad wright
does a rewrite brad wright sends that
next one today and again so it looks
like actually amazon prime have had
their fingertips in this tv series from
day one
jon jones said he had a shooter i'd love
to know what brad said john get upstairs
get get in the comments tell us exactly
what you said um because again this
seems to be i've had a little bit of a
conversation with myself and i did ask
brad to clarify when this joseph melosi
script was written and he didn't respond
to me because he did tell me initially
it was a year ago that was a few months
ago say 18 months now he's saying it was
before covid like i said that's at least
two and a half years
so there's a bit of a six month
discrepancy there um but that's that's
easily done we've all got covered brain
and i don't know where's we're coming or
going the last two years
so
that seems to be we seem to be getting
finally getting a bit of clarity though
anyway and something and then storyline
that makes sense
but the big takeaway from that
is that
amazon are not going to drop a project
that for one they initiated it they went
to mgm and said you know actually we
wouldn't mind this we would buy this if
you made it
that seems to be what triggered mgm to
get brad wright to write the pilot
i said at the time mgm people i spoke to
felt that that was always done to try to
bump up the sale price because
um a stargate project as an intellectual
property is worth so much but stargate
project actually in development is worth
more and we do have to remember that the
stargate franchise is mgm's most
valuable franchise only um only second
to bond
so
it's like jonathan i'll write word for
us i can't upload the tweet as a picture
here yeah thank you that would be great
i'd love to do that i'd say i've seen a
few of his tweets so and i should have
put him on here so i could save him too
much but i didn't um
the last brad wright tweet that i got
basically was saying that somebody had
asked him um
whether he was involved in stargate
anymore he actually said
i wrote these scripts before covered
um
i have no idea what amazon are doing
with the project right now
um but um he doesn't believe they would
scrap a project they've spent this much
money on um like saying a big reason why
they bought mgm and he seems to be
agreeing with that i don't want to put
words in his mouth but he seems to be
agreeing with me that a big reason why
they bought mgm was stargate
um also francis like rocky
you know oh god goes list goes on and on
with them gym doesn't it but
stargate is one reason and what i was
told was very early on amazon came to
them and said that there's this three
big projects they wanted to push
forwards with and it was bond amazon and
a big reboot we're going to be hearing
about a reboot shortly i think
um
so he said that but he said he hasn't
actually done any work on that since
then he has no idea and he's had no
meetings
um he did then tweets that he was not
invited to the meetings that happened in
april
um
something that i've clarified since that
um i told you guys that actually he was
invited to those meetings it looks like
the source i spoke to that now hates me
and won't talk to me anymore but the
source that i spoke to at the time um
saw his name on a bunch of meetings it
looks like actually the meetings were
about brad right not inviting him
um but again
when you're getting sources like we're
getting from mgm people talk to me about
these things they don't have the full
picture
so we are making some assumptions
and speculating quite a lot but that's
all we can do and we don't have the full
picture when the people we're talking to
don't have all the information
uh
good channel i appreciate those because
i hope stargate comes back but i also
have my reservations especially like
picard we can talk about in a bit once i
get through this last little bit of
information we'll have a bit of a
questions and answers if you guys want
to get into the comments tell us what
you think
um
[Music]
and let's let's see let's see what we
what we want to talk about
right
so
brad wright admits he's got no idea what
they're doing right now the guy i speak
to amazon though says that they've been
interested in three years there's no way
they're going to drop a project that
they've been working on three years he
says oh the other big thing was he says
there is now a small team
um in amazon um at amazon studios that
are going through
the script and all the artwork and
things and they're reviewing everything
that was done this is an extension of
the
sort of what they started a process they
started um during the april meetings
when a lot of this artwork based on brad
wright's pilot script was produced so
they could show off to executives
apparently all of that stuff now is at
amazon studios
um he did tell me the office but i
didn't write it down
um and there's there is a team looking
at that but he says that's shouldn't get
too excited about that because there's
little teams of two or three people
looking at almost every mgm project
anything they've started to work on
they're they're reviewing amazon and
they're trying to decide what projects
they want to kick off with and what
projects they don't
and try to review where they are so just
the fact that there's a small team
looking at the stargate project he said
i wouldn't get too excited about
um but it's still cool and that's
happening
so where we are right now there is no
movement
the financial impact of covid has just
started to hit entertainment and the
slowdown in um these subscriptions there
is going to be a massive mgm restructure
amazon executives now they've actually
owned mgm and can start doing what they
want
are reviewing everything
and we know the mgm it looks like amazon
have been involved since the beginning
and have their fingertips all over this
project and we're just waiting to see
what happens next
um
what do i think is going to happen
this is speculation in my opinion
but
a lot of the work has been done
we've got a pilot script that's three
years old
i'm being told though that amazon don't
love the pilot
now but that doesn't mean brad wright
can't write another one i can't write
the development process start again it
just makes sense that that will happen
just a second guys i got and there's
something i need to get rid of in the
messages goodbye now
wake you too thank you so much i really
appreciate that and listen any super
chat things they will be read out if you
say something you want to be read out do
it that way i just need to block a user
that is sending us naked
lady things
so
brad right when i cancelled
when she was cancer i pitched mgm a
movie they bought she won atlanta's
teammates rescue destiny and save the
closure the story
and they've talked about that a few
times haven't they about how in the new
series they really hope for an sgu an
sg-1 and sg atlantis sort of conclusion
um i normally have mod z and wakey but
they are
not online at the moment
let's get rid of those guys
i started writing immediately we kept
the setup for as long as management
wasn't interested yeah this is all after
um
uh stargate atlantis ended wasn't it um
sgu ended as well um but they really did
push for a movie particularly the end of
stark atlantis but they couldn't get the
money
by the way if you're watching and you're
new to the channel please like subscribe
hit the bell notification really helps
us out also you can go to psytrek.com
there's a link in the description you
can buy lovely sidetrack gear t-shirts
and things and there's a load of
stargate um designs i've done for you
can pick your team sg-1 sga or sgu so
please all of these things they help
i've got the prices as low as i possibly
can but anything you do really supports
the channel
if you've got any questions guys please
get into the
things and help us out george you are a
legend thank you so much i really
appreciate it
thank you sir
yeah it's such kevin i agree with you
it's
it's like we said
this stargate franchise is bigger than
rocky
it was bigger than a lot of the other
movies they've done over the years um
the stargate movie was a big surprise
hit it was a movie that they only spent
um about five million or fifteen million
dollars to buy
ah go away
and fifteen fifteen million dollars to
buy
um because it was made by this other
company the company didn't think it was
going to do very well and they sort of
chickened out and mgm stepped in and
went oh we'll have it they bought it
um and then they think it was a surprise
it's still even today the eighth highest
grossing mgm movie of all time
um the tv series won loads of awards it
was the highest showtime um series ever
and premiere it absolutely um smashed it
james james bonds
yeah now that i want to see
bond james bond i want to see jack
o'neill sort of like you know taking the
piss out of bond that'd be good and then
smacking james bond out when james bond
tries to hit on sam that'd be
absolutely that would be brilliant
um
next week by the way guys i'm going to
be doing um a video with um hopefully
with uh matt who does our channel we're
going to be looking at stargate series
2. i'd love you guys to get to the
comments later and tell us which
episodes of series two you love the most
we're going to review the whole series
and it's a series which i think actually
was one of the best it really
really set the foundation for the whole
series
but all honesty it's got the weakest end
into any of the series of stargate but
the end of that series i think is awful
and i'd love to know what you guys think
so please get in the comments
so how how important oh
that was one thing i wanted to talk
about actually was
um brad wright and atlantis uh sorry and
amazon so brad wright has since doing
stargate written two other um scripts
for pilots for other shows he's also
written a movie for amazon so he
obviously has a decent connection with
amazon he says in his tweet and when he
was talking about this that he doesn't
think it's probably pretty likely none
of those projects will ever get made but
they all still could but it does show
he's got that relationship with amazon
amazon know who he is basically
and uh um and talk to him and have
enough confidence in him they want him
to write for them
so
that does show that they seem to have an
element of confidence in brad and they'd
bring him through
but i'm still hearing rumors that they
don't like what's the current setup of
the new stargate series or three it's
not big enough it's not grand enough
i personally think what's going to
happen now in the next six months
is
mgm will have a complete
restructure mgm is it exists now as a
company will disappear
um and it'll become it'll be absorbed
completely into into amazon
then
they will finish reviewing all the
projects and stargate will get a green
light i think they will bring brad right
in but i think his existing script will
pretty much be shredded
i think they'll just go look it's been
three years since you wrote that
let's do something new and now we
you're talking to us now we're not
talking to mgm you're not talking to a
cash-strapped mgm you're talking to
amazon the company that's just spent a
billion quid on a tv series that
potentially in the lord of the rings
nobody will watch
um that's not true everybody will watch
it everyone are watching complain about
it but everyone watching
um
you can now have a much bigger vision
and we're going to have in that vision
it's going to be tv series movies
and you know we can do almost anything
we're going to have a team it won't just
be brad and it was never just brad with
stargate atlantis you know it was joseph
malozy it wasn't robert cooper it was
others so we're going to build a team
around this and i but i don't think
that'll happen now until christmas time
everything that i was being told six
months ago was that amazon wanted this
on our screens by next summer one way or
another
but that was always before
the coved impact really squeezed even
though everyone i've spoken to says that
everyone knew it was coming except it
seems the big executives they all seem
to think that this cash cow of covid
where everyone was stuck at home
everybody was getting subscription
channels
and was going to go on forever and
everybody in the marketing people would
tell them no there's going to be a crash
but we're seeing that now
so
i think that'll happen probably in about
six months
so when do we think we'll actually get
stargate on our screens
it takes about 12 months to develop a
new series it just does
um from script to screen if you really
squeeze it down you can do it in about
eight months apparently
so if this were to be agreed by
christmas
we could see it on our screens by the
following autumn
so autumn 2023 we could have star gamer
screens
i asked the amazon guy because this is a
new chap i've been speaking to what do
do we think that series would look like
could we get 24 episodes
he said almost no chance
they don't do 24 episode series anymore
on these type of networks they just
don't they will follow and this is what
i've been told repeatedly actually over
the last 12 months they will follow the
disney model they're looking at what
disney deal with star wars and they'll
copy that so this source samson says
eight episodes eight to twelve episodes
somewhere in that area depending what
the story
um dictates
even if they go for a strange new
world's type of thing it's a different
story every week there will be an
overarching storyline there will be a
big bad and that will go on in phases
and that'll happen over
eight to twelve episodes as i say but it
will be really flexible depending on
what brad right story needs
so
if the story needs fourteen episodes
i'll get 14 episodes two and these eight
i'll get eight and it's really flexible
he says there is almost no chance we
will get 24 episodes
so if you are one of those people that
just wants stargate back on our screens
like it used to be
24 episodes a different story every week
a different gate address
we're not gonna get it
um it's almost certainly going to be
short series but
we could get something like what they've
done with star wars where we get three
or four series a year
so even though we might only be getting
um eight ten twelve episodes in a hit
we might end up actually getting
something like 36 episodes a year
and which to me would be phenomenal but
those different series would have
different perspectives or different
teams or different
something else but they will intertwine
with each other
that to me is just phenomenal i would
love to see that and i can't wait to see
it
so that is everything i know at the
moment guys so let's have a look back
through and see what some of your
comments have been
um
this does not sound good at all hack
says
um i think it sounds like
to me i think it sounds really confident
because like i said
amazon have been into this in three
years so they're not going to drop
something that's not gonna you know
they're not gonna drop something they've
spent three years on i think starting it
not greenlit two years ago it'll get
dumped
um
i i would agree with that if we've not
seen something in six months i'd be
really really concerned that it's not
gonna happen
um and i think at the moment we're
looking at six months
um
sorry guys i'm just trying to get the
there we go
um such a big thanksgiving drop it uh
sorry jay what's him seeing there
don't worry
um
gamer beans gotta look forward to so
they get a new show
and the show was a huge cash cow you get
100 right and the ex
one of the main reasons another reason
why amazon aren't going to drop this
show um and again this was confirmed to
me by the amazon this i think i've
really been bugging this this new person
i've been speaking to um from amazon um
because i'm just i just find it
fascinating i'm trying to learn as much
about how these shows get developed as
well and how what the development
process is like
i want to understand it i think i've
understood
um
you know nine months ago when i started
this channel what i know now i would
have done very very different videos
because i understand the process a lot
better then
um there's a lot of things i wouldn't
have said because i've misunderstood
things and blah blah blah but anyway
it's a learning curve if you gotta learn
these things
um
one of the things he was talking to me
about um the way amazon does shows as
well is that they do everything based on
metadata
and they do lots and lots of surveys
with with customers
um and but they also look at viewing
figures from the tv series now stargate
sg1 was on amazon prime uh two years ago
i think
and it was on the mgm channel
they look at those though those
those viewer figures and apparently they
were amazed the viewing figure stargate
sg-1 got in particular um and atlantis
um they were really really surprised at
a tv show that at the time was 20 years
old and got the view of figures like it
was a new show it beat new shows in lots
of different ways and so people were
jumping in and they were watching
episode after episode and this is one of
the things they look at do people just
jump in and watch the same episodes over
and over again
so say it's like star trek say star trek
the next generation
the most watched episode of star trek
next generation is the best of both
worlds
lots of people going which will just
watch that and they'll watch it over and
over again
the thing apparently they really like in
the metadata showed with star trek
stargate is that people watch the series
from beginning to end
um it's a bit like firefly they'll just
watch the whole series they don't watch
the same episodes over and over again
they watch the whole series over and
over again and this was something that
really really
surprised them
um
and and that really you know that that
amazes me
um just trying to get rid of this idiot
that keeps playing things
um
there's a lot more to the series let's
see what jon jones has just been saying
there's a lot more they do the series of
movie there's a perfect way to continue
the series i would love them to start
off with a movie and a really big impact
the problem is a movie takes probably
two years to develop um i don't want to
wait that long i'd like them to come
back with a series they can get my
screens within eight months and then hit
us with a movie that that works you know
that's much better i'm currently known
as the sales partner and why and they
sell my products very good very cool
john
uh
i like the idea of 8-13 episodes i'd
love to see that as well
um i've i've not seen as well but people
have sent them to me i've had loads of
people send me the surveys that they've
done they've also had a bunch of um
surveys out for like firefly and things
like that as well that they were
interested in doing and looking at um
and
old movies they did an old movie survey
not long ago they sent out to people
apparently they send them out to quite a
small number of people but it's the same
people over and over again that they
send them to sort of thing
so
we are getting really close to 10 000
subscribers guys
so don't forget to you know share the
video let's get more subscribers get
people out there talking about this
amazing stream star hunter redux but
nobody watches it cult franchises don't
do well
that is true um
amazon will dump a tv show on its arse
if it doesn't do well
but you've also got to remember though
that it doesn't necessarily have to have
massive numbers it's demographics
they're interested in as well
this is when the conversation's having
about babylon 5. babylon 5
is a cult classic there's a core amount
of people and the expanse is the same
there's a core people that love this
show but the ones that love it adore it
and stargate is the biggest of all of
them stargate has got a fan base that's
just insane
excuse me diet coke diet coke
um
they don't care if those numbers aren't
massive like say like love island lots
and lots of
millions of people watch that stupid
show so it's going to get made because
it's gets loads of views and it's very
cheap to make
but it might not bring you a lot of
subscribers
people did people love it enough to
subscribe to a channel for it and amazon
look at figures like that does a project
if if a project
is watched by 10 million people
but only a million of them really love
it and love will love it enough to
actually subscribe to their channel for
it then they all they see is the million
they don't care about the other nine
million that do actually watch it
regularly
if stargate only says has five million
viewers but two and a half million of
them love it enough that they will
subscribe to the channel for it
they see the two and a half million
they'll see they've got okay even though
love island has more viewers i've never
watched it myself but apparently it does
um
stargate is more valuable to them
because it gives them more subscribers
and that's all they care about is bombs
and seats
will brandily learn how to roll a new
show not a clue
demographics are awesome for stargate
it's right in this sweet spot it really
really is
so guys that's where we're at at the
moment and i'm sorry it's not better
news but i think this is as good as news
as we're gonna get at the moment that um
you know
amazon are never ever gonna drop this tv
show we can be i was actually starting
to lose confidence that we were going to
get stargate back i was so confident
before this when the sale went through i
was thinking we're going to get this and
this is going to happen by july
and we're going to get this green lit
and and i've been told that that's still
a possibility that we could still get
something green lit by july the 25th
anniversary of july 27th
i don't think that's going to happen
because the mgm thing i don't think
amazon were ever actually planning
to have to rip mgm apart
i think when they've got in there and
they've actually seen how much of a mess
it was i think maybe they've decided to
rip it apart but
um
joe is really confident joe says it's
like five chevrons locked
six and seven of the hardest though but
we'll see what happens
um
so
but then mgm started to get ripped apart
people that i speak to start to lose
their jobs when we wanted to be fair and
he got another job straight away but um
and then he started to think oh my god
maybe this isn't going to happen maybe
amazon actually aren't interested
um but then i i make this new contact
and he tells me no amazon everything
i've been told is true amazon are really
really interested stargate is the
sleeping giant
of sci-fi and they desperately want it
back so then you've got to start
thinking
i'm just glad there's still a lot of
people told my stargate look we've got
115 people watching this video right now
uh my last video on stargate atlantis is
already at 15 000 views i did a video a
little while ago on stargate universe
that's gone past 70 000 views
a lot of people still love the show and
a lot of people are still talking about
it you know
um
it would be amazing
um it would be nice to have a stargate
against something like oh i forgot about
that as well sorry thank you keeptv for
reminding me
um
amazon are looking to bring all of the
mgm products eventually onto amazon
prime that is a long-term goal and this
guy has confirmed we all assumed that's
what they were doing but assume that's
why they bought it but then they didn't
seem to happen and like the star game
went on pluto tv and we started thinking
well that doesn't really make sense
that's a competitor
um
he did say to me because there are loads
and loads of contracts that amazon are
trying to unpick
they're trying to take all these little
contracts apart that mgm have signed and
mgm signed the pluto tv deal before the
sale went through and that's the only
reason it happened
and but actually amazon weren't too
bothered they didn't have they could
have pulled it apparently but they
didn't um amazon will be though
eventually putting all of mgm products
onto
amazon prime hopefully not through the
mgm add-on channel because i think
that'll piss people off um but
eventually that's what they're going to
be doing they want to do like what
disney do they want a big movie like
creed 3 when it comes out to go in the
cinema then to immediately go into
amazon prime like within you know a
couple of weeks of it leaving the cinema
that's the goal and if you look at what
disney plus are doing they're using
their movies and their tv series to push
subscriptions and they're doing a very
good job i honestly think they will
overtake everybody in the next 12 months
and become the biggest um streaming
service disney plus i think it'll
overtake netflix it'll overtake
everybody
um but they're using their products
really really wisely to push disney plus
and amazon want to do the same
so
projects like like i said like grade
three any other movies that coming out
and legally blonde threes coming out
soon guys
looking forward to that one
um
i don't know i said that i quite like
the first one i don't know why i'm
taking the piss out of that i
enjoyed the first one but anyway
um they'll be gone they'll be going on
trams and prime that is the
that is that the plan in the long term
but there's a lot of contracts they've
got to pick
um
amazing will get marketed data from
pluto you're 100 correct
i haven't seen stargate infinity in a
really long time i almost forgot it
existed stargate infinity was awful
i'm so glad that the initial because
when this was initially
the stargate was initially it's going to
come back so we got 2015
they talked about the first time the
reboot where it was going to be devil
and roland emmerich and they were going
to come back and do a trilogy of movies
the original trilogy so we're going to
remake the original stargate movie and
then they were going to make the second
third well initially they wanted to just
make the sequel with kurt russell and
james spader and they both said well
we're too old to go and do it um and so
they said they're going to hard reboot
it and that got scrapped really quick
that got announced i've got green lit
but i got scrapped really quickly i
think that was 2015
and then about a year after that the
idea was they're gonna have a tv series
and another cartoon
they saw what star trek are doing with
lower decks
and the other series those names going
ahead and they thought we'll do that and
i don't think but at the time mgm had an
animation division
and something they thought we've got the
division let's give the division
something to do we'll do a stargate
series and it would have been a disaster
they had nothing but luckily the
executive producer in charge of scripted
material changed this the new chapter
steve wright and he immediately scrapped
the idea and he went no no we're not
doing that we can't do a cartoon it's
gonna be terrible um and that's when the
conversation with amazon started and
that's then when brad wright was asked
to do um the pilot script but just the
love of god if that had happened
um look who's a bit late for the party
just a little bit
uh stephanie brown went down the former
home of stagger tv lost to the purchase
of mgm i immediately subscribed to
prime's ad on mgm channel i too or just
you through the last two in the seu see
that doesn't mean people will follow a
project like this
this is one of the reasons why
and when the expanse got cancelled
um
you don't have to be sorry for being
australian that's okay you're not
americans okay
sorry i'm gonna be in a chat video with
my other mate very shortly on my other
channel on the mystery channel and when
my mate i stormy know
he's american and we mock him for being
american i should have said ali mini met
him a lot
please go and find us on there
if you want to come across don't forget
to like subscribe hit the bell
notification for future videos and like
i said lots of merchandise they're
really good quality actually
sorry for being american
[Laughter]
you're okay we're okay
um
yeah ouch sorry guys
um i really like lower decks it's like a
love letter i don't it's not trek and
it's not canon i think it's beta canon
some people go well is is lodex canon no
it isn't um it's just a really fun show
it's a love letter to the original
series for me to the next generation but
we shouldn't take it too seriously i
think that's why people hate it because
they think take it too seriously because
just sit back enjoy it stupid humor
i'm british i love stupid humor i love
fart jokes and things and then you know
go on our facebook channel i'm always
putting memes up that are very stupid
humor
and search just search sidetrack and
find their facebook group i'd be great
would put a thousand members on there as
well so
um
but it's not don't take it too seriously
it's not i think wait wait can we have a
discord link please if you go to the
facebook channel it is on
the facebook channel so if you search
facebook and find us on there um you'll
find the discord link
um if uh
[Music]
if you come back later i'll put it on
the
i'll put it on i'll put a link for the
facebook group on here and if you go to
the community page i did put a facebook
link on there a couple of days ago so
you should go to find that
and then yeah getting the discord and
talk to your artists the chat that runs
our discord is great and matt and he's
always putting new quiz quizzes on there
questions on there new debates um he's
always got stuff on there to talk about
so it's really really good
right guys
hello there cat doctor instead of the
alternate universe
i saw a link for a video today of
stargate episode and i can't remember
the episode it really bugged me it was
um
the doctor is getting a woman out of a
block of ice and she throws the light in
the eye and there's um
the pupils dialing
i'm gonna have to find that episode
because i
have absolutely no idea
what happens in that episode and that
really books me because i can normally i
watch two i watch 30 seconds of any
stargate episode i could tell exactly
what happens
there's an entire episode that has just
been blocked from my mind and if any of
you guys can tell me which episode it is
i'd love to know because i really cannot
remember it it kind of been a very good
episode i just completely blanked out my
memory
it must have been quite a young dealing
on their kazoo rotherby was still the
doctor so it must have been before
heroes so that was series six i think
so yeah
um i'd love to see
jonas come back i actually really like
jonas um and
yeah ancients
oh it's about to play again i forgot
about the plague
so man in the ice it was a woman
it wasn't one woman that was in the ice
so if you can tell me what that was
but guys i am going to bid you a jew
um was it an ancient that the episode
where they thought out the ancients in
antarctica
i imagine it was antarctica because she
was frozen and i think it was a chick
i think it was a woman
um so she would have been an ancient
that is ringing a bell actually
if she's an ancient how he's ringing a
bell
i can i need to watch more star game
i've just finished watching stargate
series two
i'm going to watch target series 3 next
um
simply because um
it is
you know i've watched stargate sg-1
probably every episode three or four
times
and i feel like that's not enough i need
to watch it more
and
particularly with this i'm gonna watch
the movie again very soon
she was the first episode of atlantis
was she i remember the first episode of
atlantis
i need to watch that again then as well
um she died saving others except jack
who became
talker to be saved
oh i do remember that episode thank you
so much stephanie you've reminded me
thank you so much yes i do remember that
episode
right guys i am going to say goodnight
as i say please like subscribe hit the
bell notification share the video
wherever the hell you like um
we'll hopefully have some more news soon
um but like i said everything's gone
very very quiet so we'll
we'll we'll see what happens um i'm
thinking though
six months and if it happens in six
months and gets greenlit remember you
hear it you hear it here first okay so
listen guys
happy sunday
i know you gotta go back to work
tomorrow i'm back at work tomorrow as
well um
but never mind and please go and join us
over on the machine i'm going to be on
there at six o'clock we're going to be
talking about the stupidest conspiracy
theory um in the history of all
conspiracy theories and the reptilians
but it's the queen's jubilee so um you
know she's supposed to be reptilian
apparently
so um i i think at least one of us on
the panel actually believes this
conspiracy and i'll give you a hint it's
not me
um but that should be a giggle so please
hopefully i would love to see you guys
over there at 12. in the meantime
um be safe i will see you all really
soon and if you've got any questions or
anything you want me to talk about in
the future leave a comment and we will
get to it at some point all right guys
please stay safe
i'll see you next time